the hidden truth about Zeek and God
Valley has finally been revealed in one
piece and everything we thought we knew
about the Rocks Pirates might actually
be wrong was zebic the hero all along
did Oda trick us on purpose let's talk
about it right now you guys all the
drill if you enjoy my one piece videos
and you want to see more in the future
leave a quick like right now for that
YouTube algorithm and if you want to
help this channel attain devil fruit
Awakening by hitting 2 million
subscribers do me a huge favor and
subscribe right now we are so close
finally this video will of course
contain one piece manga spoilers so
please proceed with caution you have
been warned 44 years ago the infamous
pirate Rox dzec formed an overpowered
crew on the pirate island of haosu this
straightup legendary group included
young Whitebeard kaido big mom Shiki
silver ax Wang XI and Captain John among
others it also included whitebeard's
baby mama Buckingham Stussy and former
Empress of the Kuja tribe gloriosa and
also I guess big mom's Chef guy was
there as well there were even more
members of the crew that are yet to be
revealed but in general we know that
these were extremely powerful and highly
ambitious Pirates Who came together for
a common goal but they still maintained
their own individual goals and interests
they didn't pledge unconditional loyalty
to Captain zebic they joined him because
they believed that this would serve
their own best interests and the Rocks
Pirates are known to have often bickered
with each other and with their Captain
there was just a massive amount of ego
oozing out of this one crew and so drama
between them was inevitable Rox dzec
himself was a unique pirate Captain
because it seems that his end goal
wasn't to remain a pirate or even to
become the pirate king Zeek had much
grander plans and his ultimate goal was
to overthrow the world government and
become the king of the world and this
wasn't just empty words either Zeek
openly declared war on the world
government and he fought against them
for 6 years until everything finally
came to a head 38 years ago at God
Valley for years our knowledge of the
god Valley incident was extremely
limited we knew that a bunch of
important Celestial dragons were present
at an island known as God Valley and
some of their slaves were there as well
the Rocks Pirates eventually attacked
this island and the world government
became desperate to rescue the world
Nobles from zebek Goldie Roger and the
Roger Pirates eventually showed up as
well and vice admiral GARP was
ultimately put in charge of defeating
the Rocks Pirates and protecting the
celestial dragons at this time GARP and
Roger were massive Rivals and yet for
whatever reason during the god Valley
incident they decided to team up against
Zeek and the Rocks Pirates this is
extremely strange but it became even
stranger once we finally learned what
the god Valley incident actually was we
were initially told that Roger and GARP
won the battle zebek was killed and the
Rocks Pirates disbanded after that the
entire island of God Valley was erased
from history by the world government it
was it was likely destroyed like L Lucia
and it was also then erased from all
historical record making it as if the
island never even existed but even
knowing all of that there was still so
many Mysteries surrounding this
notorious incident why were all the
world Nobles there in the first place
how did zebek know they were there and
why exactly did he attack what in the
world could possess Roger and GARP to
team up against the Rocks Pirates just
to help out some Celestial dragons why
haven't you subscribed yet and smashed
that like button for the YouTube
algorithm you know all the big questions
after years of wondering Oda finally
began unraveling the Dark Truth About
God Valley in chapter 10,095 of the
manga and the revelations continued in
the several chapters that followed God
Valley was an island in the West Blue
that wasn't affiliated with the world
government it was an independent Kingdom
and it got the name God Valley because
it was blessed by God with a lot of
Natural Resources however 38 years ago
God Valley became became the location of
a horrible tournament organized by the
celestial dragons this is a tournament
that takes place once every 3 years and
it takes place at different locations
each time one of the reasons why God
Valley was apparently selected 38 years
ago was simply because the world Nobles
considered the name God Valley to be
Blasphemous they saw themselves as the
true gods of the world and some small
independent Kingdom had no right to
refer to a god or gods in its name and
yes of course this is an extremely silly
reason to attack Kingdom but the
celestial dragons are deranged eag
Maniacs so are any of us really
surprised by this the world government
straight up occupied the island of God
Valley and turned it into the sight of
their human hunting tournament oh yes
just in case you didn't think that the
world nobles were bad enough already it
turns out that every 3 years they pick a
new island and hunt down its native
population for sport they also throw in
any slaves that have been giving them
trouble into the mix and then they hunt
them as well the winners of the
tournament are chosen based on a points
system basically the more people you
hunt down the more points you get the
most successful competitors will receive
extremely rare and valuable prizes such
as a mythical Zone devil fruit even
before the tournament started a young
sir figer land Garling killed the king
of God Valley for speaking out against
the cruelty of the tournament the fact
that he killed someone before the
official start of the competition
actually cost guardling 10,000 points
but he wasn't even upset by the fact
that he was starting the competition
with 10,000 points points in the
negative he actually said that he needs
a handicap to make things more
interesting the people that were going
to be hunted down during the tournament
are referred to as rabbits and there are
13 super rare rabbits who are worth
10,000 Points each there are an
additional 150 rare rabbits who were
worth some extra points and one hit
kills also earned the hunters an
Excellence bonus upwards of 200 World
Nobles are competing in the tournament
and these include representatives of
some of the most prominent cel Cal
Dragon families including figer land
manm and so on the innocent people
referred to as rabbits are given an hour
to hide and then the hunt begins among
the slaves who were to be hunted As
Rabbits during the tournament were a
young Bartholomew Kuma a young Emporio
Ivanov and a young slave girl named
Jenny in chapter 106 we learned that
some of the treasures that the world
Nobles are handing out as prizes to the
winners were apparently stolen from
haosu AKA fed Island the same Pirate
Island that serves as the headquarters
of the Rocks Pirates GARP is initially
on vacation during the incident and he
fully expects rocks to hit back at the
world Nobles for stealing his treasure
GARP doesn't really seem to care about
this but when he hears that his rival
Goldie Roger became involved in the
incident GARP decided to travel to God
Valley himself back on the island ianov
reveals to the other slaves that the
world Nobles are planning to kill over
100,000 people on God Valley over the
course of the next 3 weeks afterwards
they will steal the Island's Rich
resources and then erase the entire
Island from the map even though some
slaves believe that if they survive
those three weeks they will be rewarded
with their freedom Ivanov explains that
no one actually survives these
tournaments no one is freed everyone is
killed there is no way to win the game
the only way to win is to escape the
game altogether Jenny has learned that
the prizes for the tournament include
incredibly rare and valuable devil
fruits including the mythical azour
dragon fruit also known as the U noi
model seu and the Popa fruit also known
as the niku niku noi jinny believes that
these rare and highly sought-after
prizes are the key to escaping the game
the plan is to steal some of the fruits
and then use their powers to escape the
island jinny also managed to send out
messages about what's happening on the
island a few weeks earlier and of course
she mentioned the lucrative prizes and
this makes God Valley a prime target for
powerful Pirates like rocks and and
Roger if pirates disrupt the tournament
it will give the slaves a chance to
escape amidst all the chaos luckily for
Jenny her message did get through and a
bunch of pirates suddenly attack the
world government forces off the coast of
God Valley soon after both the rock
Pirates and the Roger Pirates make
landfall on God Valley and Garling and
His holy Knights are forced to fight the
Pirates instead of focusing on the
tournament GARP and his forces also
arrive and absolute chaos in s this
allows Ivanov and Kuma to sneak their
way into the middle of the island and
steal the rare devil fruit prizes Kuma
manages to eat his fruit the niku niku
noi but Ivanov fails to eat the UA noi
because big mom arrives and takes it
from him as we know big mom would
eventually give this fruit to kaido
sometime during the god Valley incident
and she apparently gave it to him in
order to save his life as a result kaido
became indebted to big mom later on in
the story now we still don't know how
the god Valley incident end ends
although we do know that Kuma managed to
save the lives of at least 500 people
using his newly acquired devil fruit
power that said these shocking
revelations about what the god Valley
incident really was shed new light onto
rockd zebic and his character they also
bring into question a lot of the things
that we've been told so far about the
conclusion of the incident including
that part about GARP and Roger
apparently teaming up in order to kill
zebic like hold on let's back up here
with the rapid case of the god Valley
flashback and with the light-hearted
style that one piece is sometimes known
for it's easy to overlook just how
messed up the events at God Valley
actually are the celestial dragons were
planning to kill over 100,000 innocent
people for sport including men women
children elderly people disabled people
everyone there is absolutely no way for
this tournament to be excused or
Justified on any level so what was GARP
thinking relaxing on vacation and
referring to the tournament as the
celestial dragons little field trip did
he not know what was actually happening
or did he know and not care until Roger
decided to show up I certainly hop that
he didn't realize what was actually
happening because if he did know and he
acted so nonchalantly about the brutal
killing of all those human beings then
GARP is not a hero if that were the case
then GARP would not be a good person in
any way if Zeek and the Rocks Pirates
arriving on God Valley stopped the
tournament and allowed innocent people
to be saved then the real hero here is
Zeek we don't know what exactly Roger
did and he might have been a hero too
but if what we were initially told is
true and GARP and Roger really teamed up
to defend the celestial dragons and
defeat zebic then they are the villains
of this story now don't get me wrong
from everything we know about the Rocks
Pirates it seems clear that they are
mostly self-interested opportunists who
do whatever it takes to advance their
own goals they don't appear to be
virtuous Heroes who fight for justice or
who sacrifice themselves for the sake of
others but if they came to God Valley to
disrupt the tournament and to attack the
celestial dragons then they are the
heroes of that incident the tournament
needed to be stopped by any means
necessary and the people organizing the
tournament needed to be dealt with
permanently sure the Rocks Pirates
didn't come to God Valley with righteous
intentions but they ended up doing the
righteous thing they fought against the
real villains and this helped the heroes
including the slaves who were able to
use the chaos to escape at the very
least Zeek and The Rock Pirates were
anti-heroes
they did the right thing but for selfish
reasons however the right thing is still
the right thing and they should be
commended for it in fact years before
the incident Zeek had already declared
war on the world government and he vowed
to overthrow this evil regime and become
the new king of the world again you
might say he's doing this for selfish
reasons because he wants wealth and
power for himself but still it's hard to
imagine that any ruler would be worse
than the celestial dragons and this is
especially the case once we found out
what these monsters were really doing on
God Valley if ze's goal was to destroy
people who are as evil and murderous as
the world Nobles then why shouldn't we
be rooting for Zeek to succeed from
everything we know so far we absolutely
should be supporting based Zeek against
the vile totalitarian regime of the
celestial dragons so what's going on
here why did the god Valley incident
apparently end with GARP and Roger
joining forces in order to ensure that
the world government wins and Zeek loses
something doesn't add up even if Garb
didn't initially know what was really
happening at God Valley he had to have
learned the truth when he arrived on the
island so I'm just going to come out and
say it if after learning what the
celestial dragons were really doing
there GARP and Roger decided to protect
them against zebek then GARP and Roger
are the villains zebek absolutely had
the right idea when he decided to attack
the world Nobles and when he declared
war on the world government there are
only two scenarios that can somewhat
redeem Roger and GARP here the first is
that zebek went too far and decided to
start killing even the the children of
celestial dragons we know that Roger
found baby Shanks inside a treasure
chest on God Valley and Shanks is of
course a Celestial Dragon from the figer
land Noble family just like the leader
of the Holy Knights St figland Garling
so maybe Roger and Garb decided that
they had to stop Zeek in order to
protect innocent children like Shanks
the second scenario is that God Valley
didn't end the way we have all been led
to believe maybe Roger GARP and Zeek met
up and came to the realization that the
world Nobles monsters who need to be
stopped GARP and Roger then helped zebec
fake his own death and constructed an
elaborate story about how they defeated
him this means that Zeek is still out
there somewhere waiting for the right
moment to make his move against the
world government now that would be
interesting and it would also explain
the massive inconsistency between what
GARP and rogers's values seem to be and
what their actions were during the god
Valley incident and all of this really
makes me think about the Declan since we
know that all three of these guys just
happen to have the D in their names we
know that years later yet another member
of the D Clan Blackbeard would pay
tribute to zebek by naming his Flagship
vessel the saber of zebic so what is the
connection here from what we've seen so
far zebic and Blackbeard seem to be much
darker and more violent figures than say
Roger GARP Ace dragon or Luffy and yet
they all share that Declan connection
could it be that there are two sides to
the d The Dusk and the dawn The Dusk
side is the dark side and this side is
represented by people like zebic and
Blackbeard this is the destructive side
in order for a new system to be
established the old one must be
destroyed by any means necessary if you
want to establish a new order in the
world you first have to dismantle the
old one the dawn side is the light the
side represented by people like dragon
and Luffy this side has Noble ideals and
it creates creates the New World Order
after the old one is destroyed it is the
constructive side and it brings about
the new dawn this is why we have members
of the Declan who are so drastically
different that is why both Blackbeard
and Luffy bear the same the initial in
order to change the world you need both
destruction and creation you need people
like zebic and Blackbeard who are
willing to do whatever it takes to
overthrow the old system and then you
need people like Luffy and dragon who
are prepared to build a new system using
Noble ideals like justice and fairness
you need both the dusk of the old world
and the dawn of the new one okay real
quick do you think that zebek was a
villain or was he actually a hero all
along or maybe he was something in
between like an anti-hero let me know
what you think right now down in the
comments if you're looking for another
epic one piece video to watch next don't
ignore this video on how Shanks being a
Celestial Dragon changes everything we
thought we knew about the world of One
Piece link on screen and in the
description if you enjoyed this one
piece video and you want to see more in
the future leave a quick like right now
and if you want to help this channel
awaken the true power of its devil fruit
by hitting 2 million subscribers do me a
huge favor and
subscribe